welcome back tech Enthusiast today we
have an exciting topic to explore
together AWS glue have you ever wondered
how to make your data preparation
process in the cloud faster easier and
more efficient well look no further
because AWS glue is here to
revolutionize your data analytics
pipeline in this video we'll dive deep
into the world of AWS glue and cover its
features and understand why it's a game
changer for data professionals like you
so let's get started but before that do
subscribe to our YouTube channel for
more such interesting videos and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn so if you want to want more
about cloud computing platforms Cloud
Computing Services and its various other
interesting in-depth Concepts then a
caltic postgraduate program in cloud
computing will be the right choice for
you this cloud computing postgraduate
program will help you become an expert
in Azure AWS and gcp this in-depth cloud
computing certification course lets you
master key architectural principles and
develop the skills needed to become a
cloud expert so do check out the course
link mentioned in the description
introduction to AWS glue before we delve
into the wonders of ews glue let's set
the stage with some crisp data did you
know that as of 2022 more than 90 of the
world's data had been generated in the
past two years alone mind boggling right
this explosion of data means that
organizations need powerful tools to
process and analyze it effectively and
that's where AWS glue comes in but the
question is what is AWS glue well AWS
glue is a fully managed extract
transform and load it simplifies the
process of preparing and loading data
for analytics purposes making it easier
for businesses to derive valuable
insights from their data let's break
down its key features that make it stand
out from the crowd first is data catalog
now imagine having a centralized
metadata repository that automatically
discovers and catalogs your data sources
AWS glues data catalog does just that it
acts as a centralized metadata store
enabling you to easily find track and
manage your data assets with the data
catalog you can effortlessly search for
specific data sets understand their
structure and establish relationships
between different data sources the
streamlines the entire data preparation
process saving you valuable time and
effort second is data crawlers now let's
talk about AWS glues data crawlers these
powerful creatures automatically scan
your data sources such as Amazon S3
bucket or relational databases to infer
the schema and populate the data catalog
imagine the time you'll save by not
having to manually Define and update
schemas for ever growing data sets the
data crawlers take care of the heavy
lifting leaving you with more time to
focus on analyzing the data and
extracting insights now AWS close ETL
jobs are the heart and soul of the
service they enable you to build
sophisticated data transformation
workflows using a visual interface or
code powered by apache's part with ETL
jobs you can effortlessly transform your
data from one format to another apply
complex business logic and cleanse the
data to ensure its quality and integrity
AWS load takes care of the underlying
infrastructure automatically scaling the
resources to handle large data sets and
parallel processing it's a true game
changer for data engineers and analysts
alike then comes serverless architecture
now AWS clue operates on a serverless
architecture meaning you don't have to
worry about provisioning or managing
servers it dynamically scales resources
based on your data processing needs
ensuring optimal performances and cost
efficiency this serverless approach
frees you from infrastructure management
and allows you to focus solely on your
data and Analysis is code generation and
job orchestration now AWS glue offers
two ways to create edl workflows visual
interface and code generation for those
who prefer a visual approach AWS glue
provides an intuitive graphical
interface where you can visually design
your ETL workflows by connecting data
sources applying transformation and
defining output destinations on the
other hand if you're more comfortable
with coding AWS glue generates python or
Scala code that you can customize to fit
your specific requirements so now let's
take a closer look at how AWS Loop work
it's magic when you create an AWS blue
ETL job it generates an ETL job under
the hood AWS glue leverages the
scalability and performance of ETL tools
to process your data efficiently now
here's a simplified representation of
the AWS blue workflow first AWS glow
extract data from your specific sources
which can include databases data lakes
or streaming platforms then it applies
transformation to the database is on
your defined logic now these
transformation could involve filtering
aggregating joining or even applying
machine learning algorithms to derive
insights from the data finally AWS glue
loads the transom data into a desired
Target destination such as data
warehouse data lake or bi tool now let's
talk about data versioning and lineage
AWS loot doesn't just stop at data
preparation it also provides powerful
data versioning and lineage capabilities
with data versioning you can track
changes to your data set over time
allowing you to access and revert to
previous versions if needed data lineage
on the other hand helps you understand
the original and transformation history
of your data ensuring data quality and
compliance so now let's discuss a very
popular use case of azure glue that is
real-time analytics imagine you're
working for a retail company that wants
to analyze customer behavior in real
time using AWS glue you can extract data
from various sources such as your
transactional database web logs and
social media fields and transform it
into a unified format this Consolidated
data can then be seamlessly loaded into
analytics tools like Amazon redshift or
Amazon Athena for further analysis but
AWS clue we can unlock valuable insights
identified Trends and make data-driven
decision faster than ever before and
there you have it folks a glimpse into
the power and potential of AWS glue also
to help you understand the demand of
cloud computing its Concepts like AWS
glue and the impact of accounting
postgraduate program in cloud computing
is a success story of one of our
Learners to boost your confidence do
watch this video
and I am currently living in Algeria I
wanted to experience what is like to
live I also realized that to get a new
job I needed to have a professional
certification in cloud computing so last
year I started the postgraduate program
in cloud computing in association with
Caltech constant video that with this
course I had the choice to study while I
continue and that is how I got this new
job offer with 60 percent salary high in
Finland I will be leading the cloud
computing unit of my new company we
cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are also remember in today's
data driven World efficiency is key and
AWS glue empowers you to harness the
true potential of your data without
getting caught up in the intricacies of
ETL so go ahead and give AWS glue a try
your data analytics pipeline will thank
you also if you like this video then
please do give it a thumbs up and share
it with your friends and if you have any
questions related to this video then
please feel free to ask away in the
comment section our team will reach out
to you as soon as possible thank you and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign